si te encuentras en un cuarto te invito
a hacer un experimento busque en el
cuarto algo que esté hecho de madera o
de papel o de tela y que lleve cierto
tiempo en la habitación de manera que
esté a la misma temperatura que el
cuarto y ahora busca algo que esté hecho
de metal y que también lleve algo de
tiempo dentro del cuarto y que no tenga
su propia fuente de energía por lo que
no puedes usar la computadora por
ejemplo pero seguro que no te costará
trabajo encontrar algo de metal en donde
te encuentres que lleve cierto tiempo en
ese cuarto ahora vamos a tocar ambos
objetos y te darás cuenta de que aunque
ambos objetos lleven cierto tiempo en el
mismo cuarto
el metal se sentirá más frío y eso es un
acertijo porque ambos objetos llevan
cierto tiempo en la misma habitación por
lo que ambos deben de tener la misma
temperatura ambiente vamos a poner un
ejemplo concreto
digamos que el cuarto está a una
temperatura de 21 grados celsius y la
clave para que sintamos el metal más
frío es que la temperatura ambiente sea
menor que la temperatura del cuerpo y la
temperatura corporal típicamente es de
37 grados celsius
esta es la temperatura corporal
aunque la temperatura de tu piel puede
ser diferente de ésta pero supongamos
que se aproxima a 37 grados celsius y lo
que sucede es que el objeto de metal o
la superficie de metal no es más fría no
tiene un menor promedio de energía
cinética que la superficie de madera
como ambos tienen cierto tiempo en el
mismo cuarto ambos tendrán una
temperatura de 21 grados celsius
entonces qué es lo que pasa con el metal
porque nuestra piel le dice a nuestro
cerebro que el metal es más frío
la respuesta más sencilla es que el
metal es más eficiente en quitarnos el
calor y porque es mejor quitando el
calor imaginemos que estos son los
átomos en la superficie de nuestra piel
imaginemos que esta es mi mano sobre
esta superficie mi piel tiene una
energía cinética promedio que estará
relacionada con la temperatura corporal
de 37 grados celsius por lo que estos
átomos estarán vibrando y rebotando y
quizá haya algunos enlaces entre los
átomos de carbono y los otros átomos de
mi piel lo que evita que anden sueltos
por completo pero sin duda estarán
oscilando y rebotando un poco entre
ellos que podría deberse a ciertas
fuerzas electrostáticas pero tendrás
cierta cantidad de energía cinética
y digamos que mi mano está tocando a
ambas superficies por lo que tengo la
superficie de madera en este color
tengo la superficie de metal en este
otro color la superficie de metal ya
habíamos mencionado se va a sentir más
fría aquí dibujamos el resto de mi mano
para que se den una idea
qué está pasando aquí veamos esto a
nivel microscópico primero que nada la
superficie de madera será irregular así
que tendremos átomos aquí hay huecos
aire más moléculas por aquí pero habrá
huecos acá en donde habrá aire y también
habrá huecos internos así está la madera
mientras que el metal es mucho más denso
y la superficie es más lisa los átomos
de metal están más juntos y son más
densos la superficie no tendrá huecos
internos ni bolsas de aire
así que qué va a pasar pues ya
comentamos que la transferencia de calor
se da desde el sistema con mayor
temperatura o el objeto con mayor
temperatura hacia el sistema u objeto de
menor temperatura aquí habrá siete
energía cinética promedio consistente
con los 21 grados celsius que es la
temperatura del cuarto lo mismo ocurre
aquí donde habrá la misma energía
cinética promedio estos átomos estarán
vibrando y rebotando entre ellos debido
a las fuerzas electrostáticas y espero
que esto les ayude a darse cuenta de lo
que está ocurriendo aquí pero mi mano
está más caliente por lo que las
moléculas y los átomos en mi mano
estarán chocando y rebotando contra las
moléculas de la madera y la es
transferida en energía cinética pero
debemos darnos cuenta que no estamos
teniendo mucho contacto con la madera
porque su superficie no es lisa y tiene
muchos huecos por lo que esta molécula
no rebota contra otra partícula sino que
se encuentra con una bolsita de aire
aunque algunas partículas de madera
comenzarán aquí
energía cinética de mi piel yo lo
sentiré como algo de frío quizá esta
partícula me quitó algo de energía
cinética y luego golpea esa partícula y
transfiere algo de esa energía cinética
pero lo hará más lento comparado con el
metal ya que en el metal no hay tantos
huecos y habrá más contacto con mi mano
de la que hay con la madera además en la
madera hay bolsas o paquetes de aire
como aquí acá y allá y además la madera
es menos densa por lo que habrá menos
colisiones y llevará más tiempo para que
la energía cinética sea transferida
lejos de mi mano
el metal por otra parte en el momento
que algo toca el metal este átomo
golpeará a este otro y éste a su vez gol
para a este otro de ahí y así
sucesivamente
de manera que la energía cinética se
transferirá muy rápidamente en el metal
por lo que nos quitará más calor de la
piel esta molécula le quitará energía a
mi piel pero va a rebotar con sus
vecinos y les transferirá esta energía
cinética y la va a perder rápidamente
por lo que estará lista para que rebote
en ella otra vez otras moléculas de mi
piel y quitan más energía cinética por
lo que va a quitarme el calor más rápido
tenemos una transferencia de calor más
rápida de lo que tenemos con la madera
desde el punto de vista del cuerpo el
que se nos quite el calor más rápido
aunque ambas superficies están a la
misma temperatura el cuerpo lo va a
percibir como un enfriamiento